the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so let's get started where a lot of
stuff happened in the last lecture so I
spent a little more time to review what
we talked what are the key points here
so what we did in the last lecture is to
ask the question what are the electron
energy levels in a periodic potential
and that's a really the periodic means
we start thinking about the crystals and
we started with one-dimensional simple
pictures where I have periodic
arrangement of atoms and so if you
recall before last lecture what we're
considering
really I'll confine the states of an
atom of a molecule where the wave
function is spatially just a run atom
around the molecule right
and in this periodic structure what
could happen is the wave function the
original belong electron belong to atom
now they have space to flex their wave
function muscles right you go through
the whole crystal and in that expression
what we have is we use the extended of
wave of different wave vectors right and
and so this each of this V vector
represent or say a wave function and if
I have n atoms and we vector is every 2
pi K times a every 2 pi I have a
repeating so at the end I'm drawing only
2 pi in fact I'm drawing from negative
PI to plus PI and I'll give you the
rationale today why we draw this way and
then it's important to recognize that
between minus PI over a 2 plus PI over a
we have a total of 4 endpoint
because I have n atoms in this periodic
direction and each point of course
represent a quantum state except I do
not have the spin included so each so if
I have n points in fact I have two n so
it's a symmetric right from minus PI
over 2 plus PI or a so I only draw you
see I only draw the other they want half
of it right and if I come from here to
here there are really two important
states right and with that I say if I
give hydrogen as an example if I could
arrange them in one dimensional periodic
fashion then because each hydrogen has a
wine electron and at the absolute zero
temperature the lowest energy level
feels and you will feel to the middle of
the band right and if I have three
electrons lithium you'll feel to hear it
feels to the middle of the band and the
index those are the metals where at the
lung zero temperature the there are
seven if it's very little energy you can
move around those electrons near the top
where the uppermost energy level they're
filled with the electron this is called
the Fermi level right I absolutely the
upper most energy level where electrons
are at the Fermi level and if you read
the different books sometimes people
will call either long zero temperature
they'll see that's also Fermi level but
as a more better way is a long zero
temperature this one can shift a loop
around that position and that's say it's
better call them chemical potential okay
so different books sometimes they
distinguish sometimes they do not
student came to me and say what is a say
in electrical engineering for example if
you like read electronics they always
call that fermi-level long zero
temperature is always called terminable
okay and so this is a of course it feels
to the top then there is a gap in energy
that means no electrons can exist with
that specific energy in the crystal
so no waves allowed and so if I have two
electrons because they again at zero you
will feel to the upper most of the
lowest band there right and now because
there is a gap electron does not have
enough energy to go to the next level if
that gap is large so if we for large gap
the electron cannot move because there
is no quantum state now everything is
the field here there's a normal quantum
state this electron can move to so the
Fermi exclusion principle I say you
can't have more than one electron per
quantum state so this is the case where
the electron in the material they're
always the charge right but you got an
insulator there is low electric
conduction so this is the insulator and
of course we spend the most of time on
this one dimension er are say lattice
chair model and if you go to 3d which
you'll talk more today you look at the
each direction of the crystal you can
say a different pure this day and
different pure this day also means the
bonding between the atoms in that
specific direction the force is
different right and so you are say a
different band structure I'm just having
really drawing this right so this is a
one is one specific direction with that
here this ax t
a 1 and another crystallographic the
Russian could be a 2 and in fact there
are many crystallographic direction in
the crystal so ideally you know
everything you know each direction what
are the energy diagram energy of the
charge and here I'm drawing to the
ration and now say this is the minimum
point here this is a say the maximum
point in the first pan here and again
the band gap this is the gap here but
when I talk about the semiconductor I'm
talking about the actual gap meaning
there this is a low at the highest point
where the electron fails and lowest
point that's empty and there is a
separation and energy so in this region
there's no in this region here there's
no electron in the material in the
crystal that has say could have those
energy that's quantum mechanically
forbidden right that's what the a real
insulator like a glass or quartz if you
think about crystalline form of glass
right this is where electric instrument
has a very large band gap and if this
band gap is smaller it's not that large
let's say silicon is a 1.1 electron volt
it becomes a semiconductor and for
semiconductors we have different
scenario where this noise energy point
maximal energy point they do not align
to the same wave vector that's the case
for silicon and that's an indirect gap
semiconductor so we have different type
of semiconductors
we have dragged a p-- we have in the reg
app directly up is when the conduction
and valence band so the upper band we
see conduction a lower band is valence
so they are happening the minimum and
maximum is that assembly vector
well indirect is different it could be
here is the energy here is the wave
vector and they may happen at different
we vectors okay
and this makes an important distinction
between gallium arsenide which is direct
gap semiconductor with the band gap one
point 4 electron volt and silicon which
is the indirect gap semiconductor with
the band gap of 1.1 and you see most
computer chips are made of silicon the
most lasers pointers made of gallium
arsenite like say this one the when you
want to make a light active device drag
a p-- is usually better because you need
a light light itself do not have much
momentum so here K is the momentum so
h-bar K H Bar K is what do we call
crystal momentum it has some difference
from the real momentum of the electrons
but say we're not getting into that
subtle difference in typical way you can
think is that this is the one I think
about momentum conservation of or say a
light comes in interacted with the
electron I use H Bar K all for the
electron in the crystal rhg use use
Parkay for the photon right now the
difference of course remember K is 2 Pi
Lambda that's magnitude right so if you
look at here in crystal my lattice
constant this is PI over a that's an
strong in lambda wavelength and photon
lambda is micron so the photon momentum
is almost negligible very small and the
electron momentum in this case if
they're different they're very large
that's why indirect semiconductor do not
absorb well okay do not absorb light
well that's a biggest problem when you
make a silicon solar cell so it doesn't
you need a lot of materials to absorb a
photon okay so this is a direct gap
indirect gap and a little bit more
terminology for semiconductors right and
if I do not put the impurities do not
put that say any say other atoms of
silicon for example at the absolute zero
temperature the electrons will be here
that's the uppermost energy level that's
a at the absolute zero temperature are
the Fermi level where the Fermi level is
okay and now at long zero temperature
some electron get enough thermal energy
because the board's my statistics
they're always the electron has a
distribution and some electron move from
here to here and that leave behind empty
states and because empty states the
electron here field electron here very
happy because there are a lot of empty
states many electron here are also happy
because now they finally have a little
room to wiggle right so the ones on the
bottom rather than describing the
of all those electrons right field
electron equivalent terminology is
describe the motion of those empty
States
that's holes and holes when I think
about hosts energy is increasing this
way this is the negative for the
electron when I think about electrons
the energy is increasing this way so
when I look at this band diagram when I
think about electron and hole I actually
say this direction is the energy
increase in the hole that's the energy
increasing for electron so we have
electrons we have holes and here where
the electron mo is the conduction band
and where the homo this one is the
valence band okay and if it's a true
intrinsic semiconductor without doping
absolute zero is an insulator because
it's frozen all the charges here and
there's no mobile charge say there are
no empty States for the electron the
mode but say normally I do not deal with
when I use a semiconductor device I want
to have a specific either electron as a
majority or hole as a majority so I dope
it so that's a intrinsic extrinsic
semiconductor difference so we have
intrinsic that's the one we do not obey
and extrinsic when we dope it and when
we talk we can dope with the n-type when
I put a phosphor or I don't p-type
so those are the semiconductors and one
more thing I want to introduce this is a
if I look at the energy electron at the
bottom or hole at the top right and in
fact that's the bottom a hole right and
when I do the because this is at a
minimum maximum point so most of time
the charge in semiconductor when you do
not deal with the heavily dope they are
only at the bottom or top region there
and because there's a minimum maximum so
I can use approximation I can expand the
potential electrical energy right around
the minimum maximum so if I do an
expansion typical expansion so energy as
a function of wall okay and I'm writing
1d you can see K in a real crystal in
each the crystallographic direction has
okay right so I'm not writing in vector
form and by say I can expand that let's
say here this is a issei conduction band
edge this is the k0 right that's where
the minimum happens so I'm going to
expand this as a II say k0 that's the
lowest the first term of the expansion
and the second term de d k k0 and the K
mask a zero and the last term is de DK
square and the K minus k0 square right
okay so this term because the maximum
minimum this is zero as long as I do not
have sharp turning right it's a if it's
an in your profile I'm I cannot make
that approximation so normally this is 0
and this one let me write it into a form
that's a lie sir so I could write this H
square K must k0 square and divided by
say to em and as M star so just a symbol
right so this M star because I have a H
bar square so I will have in the
denominator I will add H bar Square and
the D II the K square okay right so you
can say this M star there's a
second-order derivative derivative of
this curve at the bottom right so if
it's a the M star is large how is that
shape looking like flak right and R is
small the shape that parabola
local parabola is narrow and star is
large the local parabola is a fact right
so this mass is like a in fact that has
a unit of mass if I write a free
electron this is a HK is the momentum
divided by 2m that's the kinetic energy
right so by right into this I introduce
this M star as an effective mass
and I using this effective mass this is
a HK that's a more like a Connecticut
energy term and this important potential
energy term so I can describe now the
electron in this small band they
transport as a essentially inside a
crystal as a free lecture on but there
is a different mass M star and in fact
and now you can say because this K in a
real crystal in different direction
it's different right so the mass in
different direction is different so in
fact many times this M star is reading
as a tensor rather than just a single
value there and that depends on
different materials so this is a both
overview of last lecture and also some
extension in terms of the effective mass
and where I'm going today is continue
this 3d picture now we have 1d picture
will go in 3d right so in the 3d I want
to first to talk about the crystal
structure together more familiar and
then I will talk about how what had the
bonding between the atoms of the whole
the crystal together and finally we'll
use a mathematical terminology is how we
can it's a periodic function in 3d and
what are the corresponding Fourier
transform right we did a one-dimensional
we say this K essentially are the
Fourier transform so this is where we're
going today let's look at that crystal
structures first and at the end of the
lecture I'll show the best ways by
looking at the more visually I can't
draw that we also use a 2d as a example
but I
look at the 3d online okay so crystals
can be described the most important
heuristics of crystal is a periodicity
periodic arrangement of atoms right and
they have different atoms putting into
the same structure so a crystal we can
describe as lattice which is a
mathematical concept plus basis so
lattice is a periodic arrangement of
points in space and this mathematical
concept no devoid of any real material
and by doing that you can actually
classify different structures of these
periodic points so let's take a look at
a simple 2d like I said and 2d but there
is a center point 2d structure periodic
arrangement and we introduce a few basic
terminology one is primitive lattice
vector so in 3d will be a 1 a 2 a 3 in
2d of course you only have two and what
is the primitive lattice vector it's a
set of food vector with that I can use
the linear combination to reach all
other points by integers so I can use
this primitive lattice vector to
construct a translation vector and 1 a 1
plus n 2 a 2 plus n 3 a 3
well and one and two and three are
integers okay so this is a the primitive
lattice vector and the problem is if I
look at this 2d I have different ways to
choose the primitive lattice vector here
is one way if I have this one and this
one if you look at this I can use this
tool and the linear combination of this
will reach any other points right so
this is a let's say a 1 and this is the
a 2 and of course you could also choose
a different one you can choose this one
and this one right so one of the
challenge is how to lower down our
choice how to uniquely define this
choice of primitive lattice vectors the
other is Commissioner unicel so
primitive lattice vector this vector
will form a unit area or Univ a loop
right so in 2d is by this unit area if I
choose this this is my unit area and I
just repeated I will power up the 2d
space without any voice and the seminary
in 3d I choose my primitive this unit
vector form a volume that's a primitive
unit cell so this will form a primitive
unit cell right and so this is a the 1
choice of the vectors and the other
choice is a conventional you can say
unicel okay and say if you look at this
it probably is much easier if you choose
this as your unit cell right it looks
more regular and if you look at at the
difference of a primitive unit cell and
the conventional eurasia a primitive
unit cell each of this Co has only one
lattice point equivalent Denis this is
because although this primitive unit
cell has a four lattice point each of
this lattice point is a sheared by four
unit cells so each lattice point is a
one force you add up is one point one
lattice point in one primitive unit cell
but if I take this convention of wine
you can say this one is share by four so
1/4 1/4 that's in my carnal drawing
there are two points two lattice points
the one in one commissioner unit cell
okay and they so like I said one of the
challenge is even if I take perimeter
unity of each of the cell has one at
this point I do not have a unique way
the way I have many choices so there is
a cube or some butter you need way to do
it to define primitive unit cell and
this is a Wagner sized construction so
let's let me extend this drawing here I
will extend to this side so to make it
clear right so one way to construct this
is to take any of this lattice point
right here is the lattice point I
collect all the labor and lattice points
so I collected a all the labor and
points right and then I take the bisect
of those points here of this lines so
this is a by sac and here is a bisect
and here is a bisect and you have
another point here and it turns out this
one is another regular sale it doesn't
look very good
right but it's a unique because the
Annie crystal structure I can take a
lattice point I come back to all
delivering points I take a basics and
the minimum volume in this case of area
the form is a primitive unit cell and I
can use that to stack together and form
and fill the whole space with all the
voids right so it's not the easiest
construction but it's a unique and
construction and this is for the Wagoner
site's construction wiggler size units a
Wigner Seitz cell because there's always
this construction always give you units
here ok so this unit co gives you now we
have the primitive lattice vector the
primitive unit cell and I just said this
lattice is a mathematical concept right
so there are different required
different symmetry the most in 3d for
example there is the easiest is a
triclinic
unicel that i can stack and form the
whole to form the whole space you know I
feel the whole space so there's no
symmetry in the angle there's no line a
degree and the the lattice constant
between here the unity of the lattice
comes in each direction are different so
this is a general one right but then
there are different symmetry if you add
the symmetries it turns out there are
only a total of 14 types after the
crystal lattice and I will defer this
later on to show you on computer and
these are the 14 times of also called
the brothers that is ok so we'll look at
this in computer later and one more
convention of this lattice the
mathematical description is a different
crystal or graphical plans right so if I
take a a cubic structure a unit cell
that's made of Q right my question is
how I would denote different faces
different crystallographic directions
right and the different crystallographic
plans and the Commission that's usually
used in define the crystallographic
plans is let's say this is the 3d I have
a 1 a 2
Bay 3 right and I have any
crystallographic plans for example from
here going here this is the middle point
and I could have this point so this form
of crystallographic plan right I mean
any of those so if I have a plan that
intersected this you've within the unit
cell let's say at the 1.81 the ration I
have an intersection point A two A three
let me give you a arbitrary lumber as an
example so this is the point eight in
terms of the total length of unit cell
and here is the point four and here is
the point six right this is a plan
within that cube there and the way I
label this plan is this Miller index
method and and you take first step is
you take a reciprocal of those numbers
the reciprocal is 0.8 0.4 right and then
say point six you take say universe of
this intersect and then you reduce twist
to integers the you multiply by the
common the common factors right so if we
multiply reduce this to integer I
multiply by two point four and I get a
three six four so that's the
crystallographic plan that we just draw
this is the convention okay and you see
that's a pretty qb7 why you take a
universe right that's a one way to think
about this is if I look at this cube
again
for example this surface here right and
if I do not take a universe you see my
intersect say this is a one this is a a
tool and this is the a3 and if I look
like this surface here that intersect
here is the one and the other two
direction is infinite right so this
surface that will be intersected is one
infinite infinite okay and I guess
people don't like an infinite so take a
universe and that becomes 1 0 0 plan ok
so that's just the convention of for the
noting specific crystallographic plans
ok now here is so far is mathematics we
see the lattice point is abstract
there's no mass right just periodic
array and there are 14 types and but we
have so many variations in real Ward
different crystals right different
materials so structurally among those 14
type the difference is really at each
lattice point what do you put there
right what do you put there either each
lattice point is a basis okay and you
can put a single atom at each you like
this point you can put a two atoms so at
each lattice point and I'll put a
molecule at each lattice point right so
salt is a common salt is a modest 14
types later on is a face centered cubic
it's a cubic structure with one atom at
the face but say either each of those
lattice point you actually put a sodium
and the chloride
Adam not well so okay each lattice point
doesn't mean they of occupy the same
space
it's just theoretically you can say okay
this is a sodium and another direction
you have chloride you just repeat that
for the each lattice point this will
become more clear later on as we look at
the the computer okay I can't draw very
well so you will rely on that and
similarly silicon had a silicon crystal
right and silicon crystal it turns out
RC either each lattice point you put a
two silicon and silicon as income so
again that's a even at say the same
everywhere is a is a silicon atom but if
you look harder the crystal itself where
you actually put two silicon atoms in
specifically the ration with specific
angle there from the silicon crystal so
those are the bases are for what we call
lattice plus basis together to form the
crystals okay let's hold that will look
come back to look at what we want to
talk next so here is a description for
the crystal structure right and next we
want to answer what is the punk in
between the crystals
so pounding Putin shirts and what really
holding mature together I think I said
this before are charged right it's the
electron so I say electron is the glue
for all the materials okay and when we
have the typical potential when I have
two atoms putting close together so a
tip where potential curve is this is the
separation and this is the potential
inter atomic potential and they always
look like this right when they are far
apart they are attractive and when they
are close to each other they are
repulsive that's a typical inter ma
entertainment potential and the minimal
energy point is where the separation
will be most stable right so it turns
out this what's the why you have
repulsive that's when they example the
nucleus of the two atom positive charge
start to overlap influence each other
and that's always that's what's the
cause of repulsive and nuclear of course
that's when they get really close right
so repulsive part is actually easier to
describe
repulsive and typical potential form for
the repulsive power as a function of
separation one is people often use is
the twelfth power law very sharp
function twelve power right this is
Linda Jones type and the other is a user
exponential function u 0 exponential
minus r2 say and can say is a critical
length and this is the poem for Mayer so
repulsive that's the typical form that
people use to describe the repulsive
potential and what really differ between
different crystals is the attractive
part okay so attractive potential and I
said the electron is the glue right so
even for the least status a strongly
bounded the crystal is still due to
electron these are the crystal formed by
alert atoms argon crystal argon is the
gas right but if you cool to low
temperature is actually formed crystal
so we already learned before
argon why is stable because the time ago
say electron field
- they close to the let's say any course
which which which line is there I forgot
anchor three right
three or four okay right so if it's a
closed shell and there's no so each
little atom is neutral right so even in
this neutral atom remember at Adam
always have nuclei and the electrons
right so when you put them together what
for what what what's the interaction why
they couldn't have attractive is this
possibly clay will attract the electrons
in the neighboring atom and similarly
the electrons of this atom will attract
the nuclear in Libra
right so these are the dipole-dipole
interactions so you will polarize mutual
polarize each other and that create
attractive force okay so this attractive
force is a when the wars and the
attractive is a to the separation six
power and repulsive is a positive
attractive with Lydia and so by putting
the crystal together forming an argon
crystal what we have is when they are
very close which is repulsive when they
are far apart the attractive but of
course a real crystal has many atoms
periodic arrangement
so we want to stable crystal is when
they total energy is minimized right
so if I have many atoms together I
minimize the total energy so if I have
the total energy of the crystal if I do
know the atoms as I say I some I or J
right pair wise because what I have here
is between two atoms so Adam I and Adam
Jay and sum of all the atoms and the I
does not equal to J because I'm looking
to interact neutrally to Russia's and I
have here the Linda Jones that's a B R
IJ 12 I J is a separation between the
two crystals if it's a cubic you can
calculate no matter how far apart in
terms of unit constant and then must be
a righ 6 power right so you this is
total energy and when the crystal is
stable is you take the r12 for example 1
2 is the unit constant the constant
between 2 labor atoms so you can always
express our I J between further away in
terms of if you have a Q right you can
express any our further points in terms
of the smallest lattice constant and you
can take the derivative of that in terms
of lattice constant and that give you
where the crystal is stable what's the
corresponding lattice constant so this
is the simplest potential that's the one
worse potential and correspondingly this
kind of crystal is called one where's
crystal argon
and Krypton descriptors one wash
so I remember you see the Superman
there's this creep quick Krypton right
I don't know what's the C Condon see or
the temperature I haven't checked what's
the temperature and it's not a very
strong bounding okay and second Denis
what that's a let's look at it this is a
where it's really the one do our
subtraction and the next type of
attraction that's an easier to deal with
is if you have salt right and in the
case of salt sodium chloride what
happens is the sodium the electron has a
one sodium as I say one outer electron
you completely lose it to the chloride
so sodium is a positive charge and
chloride is a ligand of charge right and
in this kind of a periodic arrangement
you have attraction if it's if sodium
will say is sodium atom is literally the
positively positive
it's a repulsion it says a chloride atom
is attraction right so at the end the
whether you have a stable crystal is you
put all this energy together you
minimize them together together and in
addition to the repulsive we can put in
too close right so in a legal crystal
and the attractive potential for any
atom I attractive part is it has to be
attractive the ladee fact has to be
attractive otherwise everything is
repulsive you know how a crystal right
so this atom I you look at the
surrounding sodium you look at the
surrounding little extra atom could be
chloride right so you sum them up and
then you look at the next year that we
saw them again
that's a repulsive and you
- all the summation so we have this
summation of all our ends and if they
are say charge the each atom is will
charge Q so plot - to represent its
repulsive or attractive due to electoral
Coulomb interaction R IJ right so this
is the Coulomb interaction and it's very
simple unlikely and again you can
express further atoms say in other
locations if this is the one you
consider under any other location in
terms a unique constant and so they lay
this one in fact sometimes people write
in to our four square IFRIC u square 4
PI epsilon 0 and R 0 R 0 is the nearest
neighbor distance so that's the lewis
labour distance and this R 5 is a
constant for different crystals you do
your cell structures you sum it up it
becomes a just dependent on crystal
structure and this is a Madeleine
constant constant okay so with this and
also with the repulsive part you add
them together the whole crystal you find
out what's the nearest labour separation
that minimizes total ionic crystal
energy and that that's the stable
crystal structure okay so having said
this if you do your this is this is of
course at the minimum this is zero point
it doesn't include temperature right
some of you may do
molecular dynamics simulation for
example and in that case in a long long
zero temperature you write the F equals
MA and your F is this kind of potential
in the ration and that separation now is
another idea that is constant because
the atoms jig around so this separation
was funky our time right and that
dealing with Annika force become more
challenging in fact it's more
challenging than covalent in certain
sense because this dies out there very
slowly right one over R the I saw the
very slowly and that means you need to
include a lot of atoms together to do
your simulation increase the your domain
size when you do a simulation if the
force is short-range it's much easier to
simulate okay so now we have ionic and
the lecture is a covalent covalent so I
have given covalent example before and
this is a when two hydrogen atoms form a
hydrogen molecule right so when we have
two hydrogen atoms from hydrogen
molecule and the lower energy states is
when now electron because of the Pauli
exclusion the hydrogen atom energy level
was split into Sigma and the Sigma star
right Sigma bonds they don't know about
one is when the electron orbital is like
what I draw here and you can see the
electron is orbited between two hydrogen
and it has directionality x' right and
those are they are covalent bonds and if
you form a crystal so
again too decent for simplicity so you
have the rationality in this one you
have the rationality in here the
rationality here so these are the
regions were most likely you'll find the
electrons right and in this region you
don't find the probability family
electron is small so the bounce has the
rationality right those are the covalent
bond and now the last one is if this
expand star the overlap and feel the
whole space those Kawana right the
electron can go anywhere that becomes
under that picture I come to the
metallic bound electron become free it's
a metallic bonding so covalent is
strongest bonding among they say for the
christos okay and in person
when we deal with water liquid there's
also hydrogen bond right what is
hydrogen bond and I think you all know
so if i have h2o
all right so i have see this is the h
hydrogen this is a hydrogen this is the
oxygen and it has some directionality in
bond angle that's a single hydra water
molecule and now when you bring your
legs molecule oxygen will form some
bounding rather than just so now you
like rhonda shear between one hydrogen i
say h2o molecule there starbound between
this oxygen and lacks hydrogen that's
your hydrogen bomb
okay so what I have talked so far is the
Purex structure
crystal and the basic notation of pure
structure and then we talked about that
they bombed in what holds the atoms
together different forms of bound and
the next I won't come back to this pure
data structure I'm going to talk you to
you very mathematical concept and this
is a Fourier transform and if your
electrical engineer you're familiar with
a frequency domain right and the
question is we we mentioned this in
different locations like the last time
when we talked about the from common
purity boundary condition right so
and last time when we talked about from
common PR a boundary conditions that we
see a one-dimensional lattice chain of
length L right has any atoms and from
carbon beer Purity boundary conditions
say x plus l equals cosine X and from
there we use the block theorem because
this one is exponential mass I K which
is the wave through the whole lattice L
is an a and that equals cosine X so this
is a block theorem from this this
equation so this y equals 1 that's why
we get a K equals plus mass 2 + 2 m pi
divided by capital a so this is how we
got one way we got it right from block
theorem allowable with vector K and the
other way we got that we explained it is
I just have a wave function here I want
to expand in Fourier space right in
Fourier series so this island
essentially they say I have purely a
function I want to use here is extended
way in in in block block away the other
one once you expand it into Fourier
series you still get a wave vector
you got the extended wave through the
whole region right this is a 1 D 1 D I
think are you all probably comfortable
because it's just a corresponding time
right come into 1d space now I'm asking
you to construct a 3d because crystal is
pure article in 3d my wave function I'm
going to write in general case a wave
function and any location
plus any translation of weight vector
that's periodic right or you need say us
a primitive lattice vector and that
equals so now I have a 3d rather than
writing 1d can you do the Fourier
representation right so this is a where
why we introduced the reciprocal lattice
and turns out if you look at a 1d the
here the pure there's a right and in
your denominator you have a so it's the
universe of that pure okay so the way I
do 3d construction of that here the unit
vector have to go to the 3d so a real
space 3d is inverted into Fourier space
treaty and the Fourier space
I also correspondingly have a primitive
a unit vector a primitive unit cell and
magnesite construction okay and the way
I constructed this reciprocal our
primitive lattice vector is if I have
the a 1 a 2 a 3 as the real space
primitive lattice vector and then the
reciprocal space is b1 equals 2 pi so
that's my two hi
okay lens becomes the volume so lens
become volume and here I have a 2 times
a 3 and that permute the subscript then
I have B 2 is 2 pi volume a 3 times a 1
this is a cross the vector product and
the 2 pi
'we a 1 times a 2 and this insure me the
that's the corresponding vector in the
Fourier space of this 3d periodic space
real space ok you will see why let me
give a few more points here and so with
that I can construct this is my
primitive unit vector in the reciprocal
space so the translational vector so any
of this M 1 B 1 and M 2 B 2 plus M 3 B 3
any of this combination give me one
point the lattice point in the
reciprocal space so this will make a
pure article risk space reciprocal space
and that's reciprocal of real space it
turns out sometimes I joke physically
living there not in the real world the
neighbor in the reciprocal War okay
that's because most of time you see
everything is draw in terms of the wave
vectors and you can of course to
construct your unity or primitive unit
cell
Wagner cell cell based on this lattice
points and now if you have your for
example you have your function that's a
periodic any function that's a periodic
R plus T
and that the way you do your food or
transform if this is due to this
periodicity you can write this function
in Fourier series right 3d rather than
1d Fourier series now you write 3d
Fourier series and the Fourier series is
you are equals and here is the Fourier
constant ug exponent sure I R times G so
like an R times K and this is a sum up
over all G's over all those lattice
points okay and I will not I I would not
say proof but I will use them I'll do
that proved in the last lecture the
point of this receiver space the the
what do you could use it's very easy
actually doing when you do an experiment
when you do a transmission electron
microscope fraction pattern it turns out
that what do you map out are the
reciprocal space you can actually easily
map out this reciprocal space and so if
you have object twist or periodical
structure right you shoot a wave coming
in and you have diffraction right and
some of you have seen greetings how many
of us ingredients greeting structure so
it turns out that any periodic structure
I will next time I'll bring one okay
you should say light on to a greeting
you only say the diffraction the light
in the refracting any say any in
discrete spots okay so again if I have
here a range of atoms and the
they say is only in certain directions
you'll see the night come out or this is
not light this could be electron beam
when you do transmission at home Michael
graph or it could be x-ray right why you
use x-ray because x-ray wavelengths can
be very short comparable to the lattice
constant and in that case in say if you
mess at acai these gradients see
condition let me write down the
condition I'll prove it in the next
lecture so your condition is if this is
the wave vector of the incident wave
this will be vector of the reflective
wave and you will have ki minus KF
equals plus G equals zero so they you
say G is the lattice point point in the
reciprocal space okay and see this is
incident reflected and coming back to Y
at the beginning we draw the electron
energy dispersion this is a PI over a
right and we only draw over PI over a
and this PI over a turns out that's the
walking our sightseer boundary in the
reciprocal space okay so having said all
this I think we really need to look at
some pictures
let's look either
so ah it's Google you may just be a
wonderful I don't need to draw anything
let's first look at our the province
lattice right and you can say there are
14 type right here is a triclinic a
different angle different lattice
constant and here the simplest is a
simple queue this is a conventional cell
so if we put C Center here put a lattice
point at the center then this simple
cube I got a body centered right and
then if I put a lattice point at the
every face I got a face Center in this
conventional unit cell you can have more
than one Attucks point in primitive unit
cell you can only have one lattice point
so if you look at the body center how
many lattice points I have you criminal
- right because each of this corner is
shared by a say 8 right so that's 1/8 so
simple cubic I have one body center I
have two
how about fifth center for right because
I say every face you have six face and
their face is here by two so that's the
one-half and that's the three plus one
of the eight corners so gives you so
this is a if you look at the deform a
total of 414 type and hexagonal is also
interesting because a lot of people
interested in graphite right and
graphite is a hexagonal structure so
let's look at ax so this is the brow in
that yes let's look either they some
real crystal structure
so starting with sodium chloride
it's probably easier let's still look at
this here right if you say sodium
chloride and here is if we look at
sodium atom right this is a here at the
center you have sodium right so a basis
is between here and here that's a say
molecule you put a sodium chloride and
every point you can look at that same
sodium chloride you repeat that basis at
each lattice point right and the loci
the crystal silicon structure
silly calm
right if you look at silicon crystal
they what do you have here again this is
a face center right there is a one point
here but you have each point you
actually put a two atoms silicon this
point and this point this is nothing in
any of this one fourth one fourth one
fourth point right so between 0 0 0 and
1/4 1/4 1/4 you're repeating that
structure to each lattice point so it
turns out this atoms there is more like
at at regular the form it's equidistant
between this and this Center and this
Center right so it's at the each lattice
point you put a basis you put a say
molecule or atom CSA or two atoms of
three atoms many atoms you can have
polymers form crystal and that could be
very long a very large basis okay
reciprocal space
let's say I don't like this
we grow sighs okay so you can see this
is a construction powerful Wigner Seitz
unity also you have a point in the
center if you from center to this
direction you take the midpoint yukata I
think you cut this plan right so the
Wigner Seitz cell looks in 3d it could
be very irregular but that's a unique
way for constructing there's no
ambiguity and each lattice type you you
construct you can construct a
corresponding Wigner Seitz unit cell so
reciprocal
I still on Google
you're nestled let's see this ah no
that's good
do I have a simple
okay so this is a this is now getting
more to what the people usually draw FCC
structure face centered cubic they will
say okay the Asscher have specific
notation from gamma to L that's one one
one direction okay and the way I look at
this the shortest distance is say
because one one wide the longer distance
in real space and universe is shortest
distance so I'll say that's the 1 1 1
Direction this is the 1 0 0 direction
longest distance right and so those are
the very complicated reciprocal space
and coming back to here this is the
broad condition will prove it next time
I don't actually know whether it's a 1 G
or 2 G 2 GS let's see okay so if you do
your you can map this out so TM
diffraction so if you do transmission
electron micrograph microscopy we
mentioned TM is you actually electron to
very high velocity and the under the
high velocity the electron wave lengths
is short comparable to the lattice
constant so now you go through a thin
specimen typically 1000 mm unstrung
maximum right you go through there and
the even though it's 1,000 and strong
remember the lattice constant is a few
angstroms so you got a thousands pure
and so it's a pure article structure and
depend on so you rotate your crystals
you can look at a different diffraction
spot right in the stocked region you
don't
say the electron go in there that's a
result of the wave diffraction and the
again well show this will prove this
later on and that's the electron
diffraction let's look at the x-ray
diffraction right so x-ray diffraction
again is the Optio wave and what do you
sure what your people say is people they
don't the imager the detector is a
typical align so by rotating the angle
of x-ray incidence you see the pics
right
again that's so they say
brad condition requirement and let's see
whether they're the clean ones right you
some of this cream peak is like this one
Oh doesn't look like I can show this one
okay so you can say some so basically
people have built libraries and
sometimes you don't even know what do
you have you get all those Peaks you
search your library and you find out
what the materials you have okay and one
more time going to next time I'm not
going to go through this here right it's
a lot longer single spot why that's
because it is not a single crystal
it's a poly crystal okay so you got the
rinse so this is all coming back to the
reciprocal space you can rotate your
crystal rotate your angle of incidence
in x-ray change your angle incidents so
you can map out the what's a lattice
constant what are the range of an
arrangement of atoms okay I'll stop here
you